so there there are there are a number
there there are also issues of sort of
body type preference and and safety and
by safety I mean two different things
right yeah I mean safety for the woman
and listen and for the man some listen
there's a there's a really interesting
literature about this if you if you look
at sort of who people select to have sex
with versus who people select to try and
form long-term relationships with them I
mean there are many men who would not
choose to be with the woman that is most
attractive to everybody because they
don't have the confidence they could
keep her that's that's a good point even
if she's not a flirt and wouldn't and
wouldn't be looking right even if she
didn't have a Wandering eye some men
deliberately wouldn't want to be with
the most beautiful people tend to match
up pretty closely in terms of
attractiveness pretty closely pretty
closely not not always it's not because
and then there are AirHeads but you
asked about income and I want to make
sure that because I had David Buss on my
podcast and he's really the expert on
this so
um we're gonna have to fact check this
with him
um but yes it's true that resource
potential is an important variable
because people have to think about
safety and child care and a number of
things but women work too right women
can work too right they can opt to work
and make money but more often than more
important than any other feature across
all cultures is that the woman
reports that she sought someone who is
kind to them
not necessarily kind to everybody but
kind to them right kind to them okay so
even if you think of like extreme money
right extreme money or you think of
extreme bodies or extreme resources
right that somebody has women in terms
of who they tend to pair up with long
term assuming heterosexual right there
that are heterosexual because here we're
making a bunch of assumptions but in
that in that mold
what is shown up over and over again in
the data is that their top priority is
that someone be kind to them in other
words they're not interested in being
with someone who's really wealthy who
treats them like garbage is that and I
think this gets lost because people
think oh it's all about money it's not
all about money it's about it's about
safety and kindness because you're
talking about a long-term Bond right now
then people say well what about this
notion of gold diggers and by the way
they're male and female gold diggers
they're I mean I had friends in college
who who would say things like they
wanted to marry a really wealthy woman I
was like really that's I just heard this
from a few people I was like wow you're
thinking about that as your primary
concern they're like nobody would be
great I would hear people say that
um you they're also the female to male
version of that it's very it's actually
pretty rare yeah right it's about safety
and resources and this also varies by
culture whether or not women tend to
work or not work but overall again I
don't you know I don't mean to you know
be a dead horse with this but it's
really that kindness towards them is
critical but now it's really kindness to
everybody is that tied to reproductive
success also and that like if he's kind
to me he'll be kind to my kids and they
have a better chance of surviving yeah
we're doing a bit of a just so story
there like we I don't know exactly what
the experiment would look like and I'm
sure the experiment's been done but I
have to assume yes right because the
last thing you want is someone with a
ton of reproductive potential resource
potential yeah who's going to treat you
like garbage chances are they're not
going to stay with you yeah or you're
going to be there but then they're gonna
have a they're gonna bring in other
mates yeah you know and so when you look
at the roots of jealousy and and
concerns about infidelity or you look at
the roots of sort of like concerns about
resource potential and all that it all
kind of makes sense in this very
old-fashioned model it also makes sense
in in the model that we live in now
kindness toward each other is
fundamentally the most important
variable which is kind of reassuring I
don't say that to be politically correct
that's how the data fall out yeah and
that never gets discussed because it's
not as edgy as thinking like oh yeah
it's all about money it's all about
beauty it's all about this it's it's
about the Lamborghini it's like no like
how is it how is he going to treat you
and so there's also something very
special to people about the other person
who is very desired by a lot of people
treating them particularly nice yeah
right like I mean you hear this notion
of being picked right yeah and there's
Mutual picking and everything is
changing now too right I mean the way
that that you know there's there's apps
like Bumble where women actually have to
say that it's yes I will talk to you
right it's not a bi-directional cover
there's an asymmetric conversation yeah
so again not on the apps but I'm
fascinated by this because it's human
dating Behavior but it's always going to
be through the filter well maybe you can
answer this because you're a
neuroscientist so can the brain outpace
Evolution where we have millions of
years of evolution that men say I'm
attracted to these proportions that will
nourish my kids the best and women say
I'm attracted to these features that say
he'll take care of my kids now Society
is changing in the last 70 years crazy
rate of change all this is is [ __ ] is
like getting changed up can your brain
outpace your Evolution which has been
hardwired for millions of years and say
you know what I don't care about all
these things
um well people can make so we have this
real estate in our brain right behind
our forehead
um called the prefrontal cortex and it's
your rule setting machine okay so you
can create new rules for what's going to
drive your behavior like we can decide
that what's important in a given set of
situations is blank you actually see
this right if people go away on Retreats
or they go to some event and there's
only you know let's say again we're
assuming heterosexual relationships here
10 men and 10 women they're all
heterosexual you know who you find most
attractive will be gauged against the
other nine right yeah and so but in a
world in New York City right then the
mean is that the distribution is much
broader and the mean is shifted perhaps
right and so you can you can't beat
Evolution you're always going to be
constrained by brain wiring but you can
condition certain things and also
sometimes people are selecting for
somebody who's really nice really funny
we get along so well I mean there are
other criteria right just trying to get
you say okay versus shallow really at
the end I mean it's it's as okay to be
shallow as being shallow is as important
to you right that there are people who
um are like they have their list right
they're like I want to be with someone
who graduated college or I don't care or
I want to be with somebody who you know
is physically attracted to et cetera et
cetera I mean the reality is that no
matter how attract two people are to one
another like at some point it becomes
familiar but there are certain people
like I would put I'll just disclosure
I'm actually become in a Rel
relationship monogamous relationship
actually become more attracted to the
person I'm with and I think it's
something through the nose it's like a
pheromone thing yeah I become very
conditioned to them right it's not that
no one else becomes attracted to me but
I become very conditioned to them and so
I don't know that everyone's like that
I've only been me but I know that there
are some people that get really restless
after they've been with the same person
for a while and sometimes that's
psychological like they never got it out
of their system they married the first
person they were with and other times it
could be physical magical you know so
there's a lot of range on these I mean
the biology constrains it to answer your
question it constrains it sets some
outer bounds on this like I don't think
for instance that we can become
attracted to like tree frogs for
instance just because we decide that
they're the only option we've been to
India
that's true I have not no they did they
had they uh they have 14 dudes of raped
the lizard you didn't hear about this I
was trying to make a little joke here
and but no for real be doing another
study yeah this is a joke no this is not
a joke there are these these guys that
gang raped a lizard and then ate it
afterward how big was this lizard I mean
I don't know
yeah excellent question that is a good
that is very important
when I was a kid occasionally catch a
lizard but it was like a little lizard
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's like no lizard he's big enough for
me
[Laughter]
take this guy to King's Landing
Game of Thrones Game of Thrones
the dragons that's what they're saying
that's the lizard you need yeah you need
the big one you know what I mean so
um so there's some there are limits
right just like anything right it's sort
of like food right I mean could I get
used like I I like fermented food so
like I love kimchi and I love Korean
food and like yeah but like Japanese
natto the first time I tried that I was
like wow it's really like streaming like
it's kind of mucousy but I ate it a few
times I kind of got to like same thing
with the uni the urchin not into it
right I hate it everyone was like you
have to try you have to try and I was
like this just tastes like bad Tong yeah
and like it's just but now over time
I've gotten a little more used to it a
little more used to but it's it's just
barely in bounds for me whereas people
love it right that's prefrontal cortex
conditioning you can you can override
things to some extent now there is an
asymmetry to all this so if you ever get
sick eating something you have a really
bad experience yeah even a bad
experience in a city I have some friends
that visit San Francisco I texted them
be careful don't leave your computers in
your car they wrote back too late they
had 11 laptops stolen they'll break into
your car in the middle of the day in
front of cops they don't care okay
they hate San Francisco that's one
incident on one street those guys are
right in one street right now some
people they have a bad meal at like um
is House of Nanking still here that
Chinese restaurant that serves kanji in
the middle of the night so good okay so
good like I will forever have good
associations to that place yeah and you
know I've had that like I got really
drunk and uh I was a really hungover or
something like that like I threw up the
food that I had eaten that night you're
never going near me it's called one
trial conditioning it took me years it's
like a hot flame you're never going near
it and it was uh Ramen right I had Ramen
and it literally took me maybe 10 years
before I had Ramen again and now I can
eat it and I don't associate it but for
those 10 years all I thought of was that
exact smell and flavor exactly see you
still get it yeah there's that aversive
thing and notice like the it's like we
tend to close up the various yeah right
that we have when we when we see
something we like like if I see puke on
the street and started to use these
extreme examples but hopefully they'll
resonate with people I'm like oh like
you cringe you close up your air Airways
why because it's infectious now remember
when you smell something good or bad you
are literally inhaling the molecules
yeah from that thing and so like this
always gets people because they're like
oh it smells like [ __ ] you know and
that's like you're literally inhaling
everything and everybody smells it
they're taking it unfortunately yeah
unfortunately yeah